good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the webinar series of the ftth council
europe
my name is ranson garnier i am the
director general of the council
and i will be moderating this webinar
today's session is titled
how visual automation helps build and
maintain a world-class full fiber
network
and it is sponsored by diplomatic
and city fiber
to member companies of the ftth council
europe
now i will start with some words about
our organization
we are a non-for-profit association with
the mission to promote full fiber
network as the most sustainable a
future-proof broadband technology
we regroup
150 members throughout europe
and among our key activities
is the organization of the annual ftth
conference
the next one taking place on may 23rd
25th in vienna austria you will find
more information on our website
this session is part of a series of
webinar we are organizing on a regular
basis to provide our audience with
insightful content from leading industry
experts the replay of all past webinar
is accessible
via
our website for free
now some practical
information before we effectively start
the session
we will record uh the webinar and the
link to the replay will be sent to all
registrants after the event
the audience is muted but you can send
us your questions using the question
chat box
on the platform we will do our best to
address them with our speakers in the
second part of the webinar
now let me um introduce you to to the
subject of this session
as you know full fiber networks are
today
accessible to 50 of the population in
europe and the rollout of fiber networks
is accelerating
it has been the case in france where
diplomatic is headquartered and more
recently in the uk where city fiber
operates
we are no longer lacking funding nor
entrepreneurs or political ambitions
however
one of the most important challenges
today is the quality of the network we
built
and the way we can maintain them
efficiently to ensure that subscribers
benefit from the full value of fiber
technology
so this webinar
focus on this issue starting with an
overview of the fiber deployment in
france and in the uk our speakers will
explain the benefits of visual
automation for telecom application
they will look at the data-led service
model developed by city fiber
and its application on a specific use
case
we will then address your questions so
do not hesitate to type them in the
dedicated section of the platform
our speakers today
are first augusta marti
ceo of diplomatic
good afternoon augustan
spent four years in a large-scale civil
engineering and infrastructure project
working for fancy energy
in 2014 he conducted a co-founded
diplomatic with two associates in order
to help businesses leverage artificial
intelligence and more specifically
visual automation
to gain in operational efficiency
diplomatic is the is a leading visual
automation provider which allows field
service companies to lower the cost of
quality and compliance and to streamline
their physical world operations
diplomatic solutions help ftth network
operators connect subscribers more
reliably
lower the cost of compliance improve
quality of experience
and drive long-term infrastructure
return on investment
and with us today is also
our second speaker david tomlin
having worked
well known and
good afternoon david sorry
having worked uh with well-known vendor
and network provider organization for
over 25 years david is now city fibers
group chief technology officer with a
mission to deliver a world-class digital
infrastructure platform for the uk
in his role david is responsible for the
selection and evolution of all powered
network technology assets as well as all
artificial intelligence driven
working practices and and new
implementation
and city fiber maybe there's no need to
introduce the company to to our audience
but
city fiber was funded in 2011 to build a
new generation of full fiber
infrastructure for the uk
indirect challenge uh to uk incumbent
operators one of the very first alt-net
in in the uk
with its first
1 million home milestone passed at the
end of last year
and having recently completed the
largest ever capital race for uk full
fiber deployment
city fiber
five billion pounds rollout program is
on track to serve eight million promises
by i think david 2025
which would represent roughly 30 of uk
market
so i'm very happy to have um david
and augusta
um
presenting the the webinar today
both city fiber and diplomatic are
active member of the ftth council europe
so with that i give the flaw to augusta
for the first part of the presentation
thank you very much ransom and
welcome everyone to this webinar so
um i think a bit of history and context
is quite important to understand
how images became
not only mandatory in field operations
in france in the telecom industry but
also a primary source
of information a primary resource to
drive
field operations and
to manage physical infrastructure so
back in
2013 france
started the very high speed plan
with um a target of covering 100 percent
of
houses businesses and
and small offices with um fiber
optical um to pass 100
of
homes by 2025
and
as per today more than 30 million homes
are passed out of 40 million so 75
percent of the homes are passed
and the the
historically
the local authority called arsep decided
that
to make it simple
we would work
under a shared infrastructure model
and
the the two
two organizations two kind of
organizations were responsible for the
network deployment the wholeseller
would be responsible for the deployment
of the network
up to
the secondary secondary node to make it
simple
and the isp would be responsible to
deploy the network from the secondary
node
up to the faceplate
the optical determination point inside
the living room of the house
it's it's quite important to notice that
today even though we have deployed and
passed 75 of the homes
only
um
13 millions of homes are
actually connected
to the network
and so you have two
um the isp and the wholesaler are
involved in the deployment of
the network for a single household
both of them they have a network of
subcontractors and subcontractors have
several subcontractors though
india finally a lot of companies are
working on the same network and
definitely the primary performance
indicator that that was followed by
all the companies
was
we need to deploy
quickly
the network and and as a consequence an
obvious consequence
quality was left behind
also what was
very difficult is to rely on manual
reporting from all the subcontractors of
subcontractors
to update the iit systems with an
accurate status of
what do we have on the field
and and actually the consequence the
consequences of of that were
quite
um
quite a problem because
uh the the network degraded very rapidly
and and and finally
very important operational issues
appeared and for example
a few months ago
30 percent of home connections were
failing
and the the quality of the network was
so low that a lot of customers were are
suffering from
wi-fi interruption
and poor um
connection quality
it became a scandal a scandal that the
national press started to write a lot
um about the the poor network we were
deploying
and suddenly it became extremely
important to work on on the quality
problems and very recently
a year or two years ago
our authority the rcep
wanted to bring transparency on the
process
and it became mandatory to take pictures
to take photos of everything
in order to
understand the responsibilities and
balance the maintenance cost in case of
damages or repair that is needed
obviously
obviously it was impossible to analyze
that huge quantity of information we are
talking here about
millions and millions and probably
billions of pictures coming from the
field and
um the the artificial intelligence
technologies
became quite an obvious solution to
analyze all those pictures
in order to allow
um the understanding of what's happening
on the field to understand the
responsibilities in the network
degradation and in order to to update
the iet systems but we're going to talk
about that a little bit more later on
maybe david would you would you like to
give us um
a
short overview of what's happening in
the uk in comparison
yeah the uk market is slightly different
inherently the uk market
is a mix of both open access wholesale
players and many sizes
we've got vertically integrated service
providers who have their own
infrastructure networks
we've got a plethora of service
providers who leverage lots of different
open access providers
um and to put it into scale we currently
believe there's over 70 alternate
network infrastructure providers of
which the majority are vertically
integrated and may well become open
access as well
and what that brings is everyone has
their own plans their own methods of
doing things
it supports a diverse range of
construction and build companies
lots of uh telecoms inside commissioning
specialist managed services companies
into that mix in particular over the
last five years
we've got a
a growth in regulated products
leveraging people like open reach duct
and pole access so whereas we started
off building our own network and so many
so many alternate carriers did we can
now leverage shared assets
um we also see material changes supply
chain costs impacted business so we
change designs so there's lots of
evolution there's lots and inputs and
outputs to that and it's changing
and it's up to us
as an industry to weave those elements
together so that we don't repeat
the problems of the past with
undocumented
infrastructure
incorrect data in regards customers
customers
configurations and service change
and and your point about maintenance is
key to or whether it's vertically
integrated open access or shared network
as much as you get in france
we have to get hold of the data as an
industry so that we can maintain records
so
um that is a key part we see starting to
develop why because all of it leads to
customer experience and one of the
things that we've all seen over the last
two years coming through
all of our communities
is
broadband access viber access to the
home
means that we can prepare for anything
and we can enable for any eventuality
but it's got to be reliable it's got to
be scalable it's got to be maintainable
and
from an install perspective it's got to
be right first time so those are the the
passion that we're starting to see come
through the uk market predominantly in
the alternate carrier space
pakistan you're on mute
thank you very much
so thank you david for
that quick overview of the specificities
of the uk market and now a few words
about visual automation and and
basically
visual automation is meant to answer
this very simple question
because what we have noticed and what i
have noticed as um
when i was working in field operations
and
what we see today in field operation
it's that even though you have manual
reporting tools that are available in
smartphones
pretty much if you consider today
operation what's happening on the field
today this
tuesday and we are blind it's um it's
the darkness and you can see visual
automation as
the bulb shedding the lights on
the the daily operations that are
happening right now at scale how does it
work
we are using and and and
we as an industry
we you can use artificial intelligence
and especially image recognition to
automatically analyze
all the pictures that are captured
during
100 percent
of the field interventions
and that low
alone
allowing to provide a complete
and objective view of what's happening
every day in the field
in real time
so
who are the users of
field automation first
the field engineer
the field engineer
is using its mobile phone while working
on one work order or intervention
and to take picture of what's happening
of the the different equipments that
will be involved in the that are
involved in the intervention so
most of this in
often the equipments are
they take pictures before and after the
work of
the each equipment and and we can use
um
visual automation image recognition in
order to analyze what has happened on
this equipment
then
a lot of tasks are checked
to make sure that the job was done
accordingly to the work order
and also accordingly to the national
quality standards
for one intervention you might have a
lot of different equipments that are
touched by the technician
and for example you might have a primary
node street cabinet toby box
secondary node
up to the face plate
inside the home of the customer so for
one intervention it's possible to take
several pictures of federal equipment
that are involved in the intervention
everything is analyzed in one picture
you can analyze several things and for
example let's say that you need a
picture of the photometer in order to
validate the the speed of the internet
the light speed then
if it's not present the the task is not
completed the work order is not
validated until
everything
is
considered as
correct
given the image
recognition
then
all those interventions are gathered
into one centralized software and made
accessible for
the quality teams
and the network management teams
and
you can you can
dive into your operation by
looking by searching some equipment some
assets
or searching some specific interventions
through idea looking
in the last one the failed one so it's
very convenient
to
to navigate
inside your operations and
help your
team in real time on the field
and the second
the second thing is that you can also
use all those information to to get an
helicopter helicopter view of what's
happening so for example you can follow
kpis at scale about the quality of the
network about the percentage of okay
interventions the percentage of
interventions that are done right the
first time
you can compare it
by subcontractor
and so it's very convenient to
understand where do we need to
concentrate to
train the people on the ground to bring
some support
um and and it's
it's it's a
definitely a convenient source of
information to find in the inefficiency
and to understand the root cause of
failure so
back to the technician
how does it work
um
they have their mobile phone in in the
hand and to make it very clear
for the entire audience of how does it
work we can we can follow uh what would
happen in the end of the tech of the
field technician or field engineer so
this is a central office cabinet of city
fiber and here the task is to validate
what happens in this cassette
and so the first thing that is analyzed
is that indeed we have a picture that is
a good picture of a cassette
and and if the picture was blurred
if it's a picture of the feet of the the
field engineer or even if it was a
picture that is already
inside the information system because it
was taken in the past we are able to
detect that automatically and we would
kindly ask to the field engineer to take
a real event and a picture that is
allowing visual automation to analyze
all the different type of of control
points
so
then when you have a good picture you
can notice that you have five cables and
that's
normal it was
um it was like that in the work order
and that you have the cover
on the cassette so the cassette is
protected
from anything else
in the environment
and then something wrong is that
two protection caps are
missing
so you can see that in the right the red
little box here
and because of that
the the intervention is not
perfect you might accept that
intervention
at this stage or
you might refuse it
and if you accept it obviously
at least you have a very precise
information in your iit system
explaining that that in the fourth
catheter
we need to bring some spare in order to
protect the
the plugs
so that's an example
of what would happen
um and how would work image recognition
to analyze
um a specific moment during the
intervention and the use cases
um
you need to to to imagine imagine what
would happen at scale
so doing that on 100
of your intervention you can automate
the quality control
which means that quality control is not
any anymore done by
um by by by teams that are driving
throughout the country but it's done in
real time and it's in the hand of the
technician so
abusive something wrong happen
happens then
an alert is raised
automatically in real time and the field
engineer can fix the job immediately
that's very important because it will
allow the field engineer not to come
back
the next day not to drive 10 20 30
kilometers or miles to come back to
um to the field and fix what was done
wrong so the fact that
image recognition can analyze all the
pictures in real time and provide the
feedback to the technician bring
some
some some some productivity
and increase the pace of the rollout
and obviously you can work
and you can control 100 percent of the
work orders of the interventions
and you can scale your quality audits
um
to the anti to to
100 of your operations
when you do that
you can start to automate some process
that's very important because it's what
brings
the return on investment
it's part of the return on investment
calculation
so for example
swisscom is a company who has already
deployed visual automation
in its field operations to
accept
the connection between the building and
the primary node
and and before that a dedicated team
with
more than 100 people was in charge of
driving throughout the country
and and
checking that the intervention was done
accordingly to the work order respecting
all the quality standards and triggering
the payment of the subcontractor so
when you are analyzing
the interventions you can also automate
some processes
obviously it saves
some
workforce
costs but it also accelerates the
overall process and you can roll out
the the network in a in a more efficient
way
and
last but not least
something very interesting
is the asset observability
so
if you are analyzing 100 of your
intervention it means that for every
single equipment that you have on the
field
every time a field technician
is coming to this equipment to do
a deployment or a maintenance
job
they will take picture before and after
the job
and you have an ever updated view
of your equipment
and because you do it on 100 percent of
your equipment you have
built
a digital twin of your network that is
already and always up to date always
reflecting the reality of what you can
expect on the field obviously this is
very interesting to optimize your work
orders because
when you know what to expect when you
know that you will work in in
in
in a high space and and you need some
equipment to go high or when you know
that you you have a very thick wall to
drill through you are going to take the
right tools
and you are going to
forecast the right time that you need to
work on those specific type of equipment
and then finally
with the pictures you can you can follow
day after day the status of every single
equipment such as a street cabinet and
definitely if you see that something is
getting
damaged maybe because just of the time
going on you can plan some corrective
light maintenance to to maintain your
equipment
in in a perfect uh
shape for
all the the
the the years over over years
um that's all for for me and maybe um
well thank you augustine don't run away
there will certainly be a question for
you i can already see one or two coming
in the box i take that opportunity to to
invite everyone in the audience to to
you know drop a question in the in the
question box they will be addressed by
david and augustine right after and and
now
uh david uh if you want to share your
perspective about uh how city fiber
implements those tools uh
for for your interest
yeah so let's let's talk talk about the
vision first of all because the vision
empowers our business and see fiber have
we built on our vision it's a vision to
create
the better future for the uk
it is it's about unleashing the
potential of fiber
and in doing so we wanted always to set
new benchmarks customer experience
by building developing and implementing
systems the processes the tools
and really most importantly the culture
about dead data led excellence
so
this means we have to build a
world-class 4-5 network
the full-fiber digital infrastructure
the platforms that support it
and we can only achieve these sort of
things by working with others as
partners be they solution providers for
for example equipment
manufacturers
our customers
and choosing those partners who
help us build for the needs tomorrow is
absolutely key
it's into everything we do it's about
co-creating success it's about listening
it's about learning it's about putting
the end customer experience this person
sitting in their home
and and relying on us to give them the
service they need to run their lives
it's got to be front and center and we
never and we must never accept the
status quo that is good enough
so
let's go back to first steps we
we build the network
around something called a well-planned
city design it's tried it's tested
it was unique to city five when it
started and we designed these networks
to serve all the major markets so it's
quite a complex fiber network has
different endpoints different start
points ring based multi-ducted network
and data drives it to the architecture
how we do the gis planning all of those
things build
a prospective model how you're building
the network
and we plan to we plan it twice and we
dig once is the plan
and in our early years
we built the network predominantly
things like the public sector networks
but we always had the concepts that we
would expand outwards to service
residential um business and mobile as
those markets evolve
in that journey it's always been key
that we had access to accurate data
knowing where your ducks are knowing
your fiber are there's a lot of manual
work
and each one of our
fiber exchanges addresses around 50 000
and at the moment we're just turning up
around about i think we're on the 100th
fiber exchange we should have about
another 50 odd five exchange turning up
this year
um so roughly one every week we're
turning up so there's a lot of activity
there's a lot of data a lot of physical
infrastructure
and that's why we look for innovation
and we look for innovative partners who
can who have the same passion about
where data can take us it's not just the
recording of data but it's how we use
that to improve the way we work and the
experience we enable for our customers
now
customer experience it's got to be world
class
and and to do that we have to have a
deep belief in operational excellence we
have to question ourselves on a daily
basis
are we doing the best we can do
how do we get to the next stage of
experience what is the plan for the next
1 2 5 10 years of development as a
business
it's about ambition it's not just about
the fiber in the ground it's not just
out about the rollout numbers that
companies announce on a regular basis
but we know that everything we do has to
be better
because it's the way it's designed
now the way we think as a team how we
embrace opportunity underpins that we
find solutions we continually have to
use the data the information coming back
to us about how we're building the
network be it from our customers be it
from our partners and be it from our
manufacturers and our active equipment
layers by the intelligence we're getting
it gives us insights
and all of that is tied into providing
friction free services
we've got to bring together the
meticulously planned and built
infrastructure
we've got to deploy ultra robust
services
and systems
we have to innovate through high quality
geospatial systems
deploying performance data feeds into
our intelligence engines
purpose-built systems
for the for the needs of the
operator for the future
but also enabling smart automation
and we're constantly on this search for
these applications that enable us to
weave intelligence
into these data lakes into these
feedback loops to give us insights and
enable us to drive automation
so this is all through data led
operations
now
one thing that we we thought about for
the last
four years in particular is about how do
we plan that journey we have different
parts of our business i've already
talked about the fact we have mobile
residential business services
and we have to move we're a reactive
manual based
environment
driven predominantly because you know
what we were doubling in size every year
for the last five years
but we've got to move out of that phase
we need to drive more automation in our
workflows in our service order journeys
to drive quality drive service
experience we've got to remove those the
challenge of the manual touches and
those high touch activities that dog our
industry historically
and that's all about a journey it's
about a journey that we can get to a
predictive
tent based future
the first step is to bring on partners
and the applications that work with us
in that journey diplomatic is absolutely
a key partner in that space
it's enabling us to embed this
continuous improvement
learn from what we're seeing get better
take feedback get better
it's a proactive framework of operation
that allows us to move forward
it ensures that we can look at capacity
to make sure it's always in place when
our customers need to receive services
it could be triggering card installs
cables runs and patches
and then we look at the life cycle and
augustine mentioned this earlier it's
that maintenance piece that is ever more
critically important it's when the
maintenance engineer is turning up to
site they're looking at the right data
they're being told the intelligence of
the systems behind them what looks right
what looks wrong who went in there
before them and moved something and they
should not little things like that make
a huge difference to the customer
experience
and that's where it starts to all come
together for us
and the work that we've been doing over
the last six to 12 months with
diplomatic has been about building these
use cases and introducing into our
business
and we break our business into three
areas inside plant outside plant and
custom premises
the inside plant is in our microage data
centers the outside plant goes from the
ods in those data centers to outside the
customer prem generally the toby or the
aerial pole
and then the customer site could be
single dwelling units or multi dwelling
units
a whole variety of scenarios
and our aim was to this first phase to
focus on the inside plan
one because we have
really strong records for the past five
years on every single patch we put in
but also because it's about culturally
getting people to accept automation
tools and insightful tools
because there's a fear factor so this is
about people this is about empowering
people with new tools to enabling them
to work better and once we get that
passion through the business and work
our partners we can be better as an
organization
now
as we've done this scaled
the fact that we now have
we have to scale our data lifecycle
inventory all those photographs we have
tens of thousands of photographs every
month we need a process
we need to evaluate those and
process those in real time
we need to derive end-to-end
connectivity between these sites to
support our service operations group in
that service journey for the first
customer turn up
and we need to develop the data models
that allow us to expand out from the
inside plant through the primary nodes
secondary nodes and toby boxes into that
data lake of history
that life cycle of the infrastructure
library
and we focus on these practical field
applications with our current working
practices we don't want to change the
business too much that people reject the
adoption of new technology we want to
empower them to accept new technology
and then make the recommendations how we
are going to use it in the future at
scale
we also quite frankly had to face into
day one problems
one thing we didn't thought think about
was our microage data centers they're
basically like faraday pages you go in
there with a mobile phone you don't get
much of a signal so we had to face into
can we have offline tools
and can we have
a wi-fi secured wi-fi within these
facilities
you know what those experiences will
inform us when we go to the more rural
areas where we definitely won't
necessarily get data coverage and
working diplomatic we face into those
challenges
to make them opportunities
and the use case we picked
is one
that we live every day it's a particular
work order it drives the vast majority
of my team's
physical layer infrastructure it goes
from an optical distribution frame where
the incoming plant is terminated these
tend to be about 2 000 fibre cable
frames
and they have cassettes in them and it's
connecting those cables from the
incoming plant all the way through to
the optical line termination equipment
in the rack
through hydro cables so we have a look
at all of the cassettes make sure
they're correctly labeled people are
working on the right one always a good
check
making sure that the cables are in the
right locations that they are
positioned
with head shells on when they start
they're ready to go nobody's been moving
things around we check the fibers we
check the parameters
and that data in itself is very useful
because we port that into another set of
databases that look at the lifecycle of
the optical losses between the olts and
the onts
and it gives us a whole set of
information so we can double check
if everything's going to the right place
and also do we see degradation over time
because we've got multiple measure
points again it goes into that life
cycle management
we look at the cassette after patching
they put it in the right place they
haven't moved anything else and it flags
it to them on the ground so they don't
need to go back exactly to augustine's
point earlier and then we terminated the
lts we checked the lifecycle of cards we
got the right cards inside slots are we
supporting right things and how does
this eventually tie into our inventory
management system to check the records
of the inventory management system the
cards are in the right place they're at
the right height in the racks informing
the next engineer when they go to site
they've got the right cables they've got
the right labels to go on things etc etc
it's all a map about making this service
chain ever more efficient and ever more
effective
and quite frankly
at the moment
this is making a material difference
to those field engineers we've got on
the ground who have adopted this with a
passion that we
we actually were fearful that wouldn't
be accepted but it has been
um and has made my network quality
assurance
groups able to focus on other areas of
our business and for the next stage of
development as we move into the odf
through to the primary nodes to the
secondary nodes to shared assets and
then eventually onto
sdus and mdus to support our customer
installs in
these
crap
been a fantastic six months so i'd like
to personally thank the diplomatic team
for their
frankly passion and their commitment
over that time thank you augustin
thank you very much
all right so i guess this is concluding
your uh
your section david uh which brings us to
to the the q a
and i will kick off with a very
technical and precise question to to
augustine i guess uh you you showed us
some some pictures of uh
field intervention
and one question is from yoland um are
all photos
jail referenced
not all of them it depends on the choice
of the the
of the the customer
um
often we
we have the geolocation of the of of the
picture and it is used to reconciliate
the information of
the id of the street equipment to make
sure that
for example um the the the future is
indeed working on the right equipment
um that it is supposed to be
but um it really depends because
sometimes you can use it even without
those information and it's still
valuable
i would say that
the more we share together information
the more we can
verify double check
and and make sure that for instance we
are working on the right type of
equipment
okay maybe another question to david
david you you mentioned the evolution of
the uk market the uh i would say the
ftth operator landscape is
is changing on a daily basis and and
will certainly mature even further in in
the next four to five years how is uh
how are those artificial intelligence
tool critical in for you to to build
your competitive advantage and and the
overall strategy of of city fiber could
just maybe
come back to that from a strategy level
for a company
so from a strategic perspective um
one of one of the things that i think
we need to do is always
drive
examples of strong use cases
that hopefully other alternate carriers
will learn from adopt to increase the
quality of their records
um and equally quite frankly if there
are alternate carriers out there and we
see something we like we'll talk to them
to improve it because every single one
of us strategically
needs to be pushing for quality led
fiber networks if you have built a
poor quality fiber network it's of no
interest for us
it costs more to integrate
um it provides a worse service over the
long long term and i think if we looked
back at the lessons learned and the
cable code days in the uk in the 1990s
i think it it weighs on the ability for
consolidation in the market which will
eventually come
because
it's just too difficult to sometimes
integrate poor quality networks
if you really care about passionate
about your customer experience over the
short medium and long term we've got to
get standardized approaches to data
quality
record keeping
in
to a consistent manner
so strategically if you're an alternate
carry out there and your your data
quality is poor
then i think you're in a in a
very difficult position to win market
share
okay
and um in august time how far do you see
um what i would say how far in the
network do you see possibilities
uh of of further application for uh
for your solutions um
you've presented the solution for for
for specific applications do you
envisage to enlarge application do you
see
um more more opportunities in
in the field of fth and telecom in
general
yes
so
a basic rule to understand where where
those visual automation apply is to
understand that
now
the technology can
understand a picture as well as a human
so if you see something on the picture
you can analyze it
and which means that our
part of our mission and our mission is
to make sure that this is not an area of
concern for our customers
and the real
job that we might that we have to do all
together is to define
where you want to apply the technology
for which use case and how to minimize
the number of pictures that are
necessary to capture
the information that you want to get
because you want to
to facilitate the job of the people on
the field
and and sometimes we find
companies that are really
impressive because they are willing to
embrace innovation and it's my turn to
to give a big thank you to to david
because he was really
a true innovator in the way they they
wanted and they understood immediately
what would be possible with this
technology and and together we have a
plan
to deploy it on the entire network from
the central office to the to the sdus
and and
and on the entire network
um it's
we are deploying it in field services as
a company diplomatic so we can we can
definitely work on
antennas radio
smart meters
and the true the truth is that today we
really concentrate on the telecom
industry because
our customers are
have important benefits in the use of
the technology and and because we we
really want to to build something very
strong for this specific industry
clear and
i i also when we prepare the discussion
david you you um david and augustine you
mentioned to me that there are still
um on the market some level of um
doubts or or maybe lack of knowledge or
sometimes even cynicism about artificial
intelligence people adopting that it is
actually for real now and that it can
bring concrete benefits obviously you
are proving the contrary but
what would be the the key factor you
would highlight your audience to make
them understand that it it is
potentially for them as well
so so
telecoms has been dulled by applications
that we all big fanfares about and
actually don't get adopted by workforces
we have an opportunity here
i think as an industry we're more aware
of data quality
and
by focusing on
the teams who get to use the tool and
empowering them to use the tool for
better effect now it could be related to
the fact
that if we support them to complete
their tasks
in an effective manner they're still
getting paid for the same amount but
they don't need to come back so it's a
it's a
immediate cash reward for them
equally it's about feeling like you've
done a good job we're creating a
a foundation of fiverr in the uk which
is going to be here for the next 40 50
plus years
and everyone as part of the city fibre
team
believes in that goal and you're
building something that will be here
maybe after you've left this earth
and that means something to a lot of
people um
so
if you can face into the adoption
we can break the history of problems of
a doctor
using tools and improving tools
and the the air is actually
it's really complex technically but it's
not the problem in front of us the
problem in front of us is always getting
people to use tools effectively
but if we do that the right way we show
that it can enable them to do so much
more
people people embrace these type of
capabilities
this is definitely a kind of change
management
issue more than anything else
yeah absolutely i can't agree more um as
as a proof point i would say that with
our customers that have adopted the
technology a few months ago in france we
are analyzing
more than several thousand hundreds of
thousands of interventions every month
so definitely this is something that is
industrialized technology
speaking
and and the real challenge is
adoption and i won't uh repeat what
david said but you got it perfectly
right
how to make sure that it's in it's also
at the benefit
of the worker on the field is something
absolutely crucial for sure yeah
i also had uh one question uh related to
um
the the way you you manage partnership
because there are different level of uh
partner potentially involved that there
is in this case uh the provider of the
solution uh
city fiber but city fiber also work with
contractors so that there might be
different a cascade of of people being
involved in
in the value chain uh of fiber rollout
or even fiber or network maintenance
so
how is that taken into account in in in
your project in your programs
so again it comes back to culture one of
the decisions we made
several years ago
was this is a long-term infrastructure
build
and we want partners who we can trust
and partners who trust us
and so we have have built goodwill we're
we're quality led we're price conscious
but we're quality prepared and we're
service-led
so we have very open and open
conversations and honest conversations
with our partner community
and they do with us
and it's all about reaching the end goal
now the end goal may be seven years from
now but we have to grow together
and sometimes we will have challenges
and they will help us over that and
equally sometimes our partners have
challenges we see that in the resource
challenges we have in the uk at the
moment we're finding the right skilled
staff but part of that is us working
with them
through tools like this
to enable us to train and develop the
new staff coming into the industry
so you've got to do it and yes it is
multi-layered
but for us it's got to be open it's got
to be an honest set of conversations
within a a fixed set of trusted
partners and hence why we spend a lot of
time finding
the right cultural fits for us for our
community
i i would say that it's uh it's really
to combine the two answers it's a
technology that is no mature and
available for the industry
and but for the benefits of all the
stakeholders because
um you can succeed the job the first
time as a contractor because you know
what to expect because you have iet
systems that are up to date and and
reflecting the reality so you can
prepare yourself better you can get a
little feedback and succeed on the field
and as an isp you have a better network
customers that are more satisfied less
churn
your
call centers are desaturated
um if something goes wrong you know why
and you can communicate with the final
customer in a much more effective way so
it's really at the benefits of the isps
and obviously as a wholesaler
you can you can
maintain a full high quality full fiber
network high quality all over the
lifecycle of the project so it's very
different kind of benefits but for the
entire industry
and yeah
i'm having another question here
around pushing further the concept of
automation and i see the word
auto routing of cable is is it something
um
we will ever seen uh we'll ever be able
to see or what is your view on that can
we you know push further the uh
uh automation of our processes for for
uh
for fiber distribution and nodes and and
all the
[Music]
all the equipment in in uh
so to me auto routing of cable is
absolutely one of the outputs will
eventually come from this
so when we look at our odf frames we've
got two thousand fives going in there is
certain rule sets about how we should
run cables and the way the right cable
should curve etcetera so there is a
natural extension that can come from
this which will say okay
you've got you've taken a picture it's
actually saying that oh this is quite a
crowded cabinet
so the
based upon the predictive analysis of
where we think the cables and how many
cables are going to be added in time
then the optimum routing
based upon all this other data in the
background is lunging together he's
going yet you want to go through this
route that's within the guidance and
every so often you know what canada's
going to be full it's been there for 15
years it's going to go normally we
wouldn't prove this but now we're
allowing you to do this exception route
because the rest of the cabinet is so
full
okay it's never going to be a perfect
world but if we can enable the engineer
who's sitting there at three o'clock in
the morning in front of a powered
cabinet in the street with the rain
coming down
to feel that we've got their back
it will be a better industry for all of
us
understand no comment on that
no comments you know sometimes the
customer knows how to apply the
innovation even better than us and it's
it's normal i mean like
nothing to add
very good um
i think i i don't see any additional
question coming through
um i i i would like to to take that
opportunity to give you you know each of
you maybe one or two minute of
conclusion uh before we write it up um
write this um this session up um spot on
time for for everybody
so augustine you want to start
yes with pleasure i think we covered a
lot of topics during the the question
and answer session i just wanted to
outline
because
i had some questions about the
technology about how to apply but how to
to balance the benefits between the
different stakeholders
i think this is really something that
will benefit the entire industry
um
as i said david we are
we have a passion for that we want to
bring light we want to define the next
generation of softwares
allowing
a good
management of field operations for the
benefit of all the stakeholders so
definitely if i had one
short sentence is like don't be afraid
let's let's talk let's exchange in order
to to understand how it can be applied
for the benefits of every single company
or institution
yeah
and for me
i think i summarize which is we're at
the tip of an iceberg
the potential of these type of
approaches
mixed in with all of the developments on
large data lake information we're
getting back from the live networks
um
gives us a
such a range of opportunity to change
the way we work
and and
optimize and support great customer
experience
there are things we haven't even thought
about now
that five years from now will start to
become the norm
and and if we go into it knowing that we
need to stretch
except that sometimes it's not going to
work
we will achieve so much more than always
just going well it's got to be this
use case but this
one-niche case
and we only do it without that vision so
a tip of an iceberg we've got to have
vision we've got to have passion and
we've got to try things you know what
and sometimes it will fail
but it will mainly work
well thank you david and on this very
optimistic note i would like to thank
our audience
uh a great thanks to augusta and david
this is typically the type of subject
that all the stakeholders of the
industry are going to discuss at the
next ftth conference taking place in
vienna
at the end of may so i would definitely
encourage you to
to register and join you there i'm sure
you will have the possibility and the
honor to meet face to face with uh
augustine and david at that occasion so
please check on the website uh for any
information on the conference thanks
again for your participation
and
well i give you
maybe 30 seconds back of your time
before meeting you on the next webinar
series thank you very much have a good
afternoon
bye-bye
thank you